and of course these conditions are
prompting local officials to monitor the
valley's air quality
we talked to the department of
environment and sustained sustainability
rather to learn more about the ozone
alert issued
day like today when you have this much
particulate matter in the air one of our
primary concerns is going to be people
who have breathing sensitivities
so it's children elderly if you have
copd or asthma
so that's why we issued an air quality
alert
for the smoke in the air because people
we want to keep people informed
primarily for their own health and
safety again take precautions and limit
outdoor activity you can also schedule
activities for the morning or evening
when those ozone levels are usually
lower don't forget to change your indoor
air filters as well
if they're dirty and due to the
unhealthy air quality not too many
people were out at sunset park today
madison kimbrough is out there today and
those that were expressed their thoughts
on the smoky haze
that was seen all across the valley
madison
[Music]
even with this extreme heat a lot of
people like to hang out
and play here at sunset park but today
it's different as you can see
the sky is very smoky even still from
this morning
and the park is empty now clark county
department of environment and
sustainability
issued an alert for smoke and ozone due
to wildfire smoke
drifting into the region from northern
california and today across the valley
we are seeing the effects of it
many people waking up this morning to a
smoky sky where the strip wasn't even
visible
the smoke can obviously make it very
difficult to breathe even for those
that don't have respiratory diseases
like asthma
exposure can induce coughing wheezing
and shortness of
breath we caught up with some people
playing disc golf at the park who say
today's game
wasn't an easy one especially for those
wearing face coverings
it is definitely tougher to wear a mask
today
it with the humid it makes it extremely
hard for me to breathe
it caused a little bit of delay people
were a little slower
some tips to help with these conditions
keep windows and doors closed
and run your air conditioner inside your
house and car reduce driving and combine
your errands
into one trip since this morning the sky
has cleared up quite a bit
with visibility being a lot better than
it was however still expect
smoky conditions all through the weekend
clearing up from sunday
into monday reporting live from sunset
park madison kimbrough 8 news now